yes we've had a policy for a long time
now that there's no good reason why safe
standing shouldn't be reintroduced in
top-flight divisions we already have
standing areas in leagues one and two
and every level below that and of course
in a range of other sports we would
never advocate an unsafe system there's
a thing called the green guide which
defines what a safe standing area would
look like and that should be obviously
complied with but it would remove the
customer care problems that we have at
the moment of people who don't want to
stand or can't stand having their view
blocked by people standing in seated
areas in front of them would you like to
have these so-called safe seats where
you do have the option of having a
fold-down seat and as far as I can tell
from that report rather steeper
terracing well i think i think they rail
seats are probably the only viable
option at the top at the moment because
european games require all-seater
stadium and i don't think any club that
thinks that it might play in europe in
the foreseeable future is likely to
invest in a standing area that wouldn't
comply if they had a european game at
their ground so I think that's probably
the only system that's viable in the in
the short to medium term anyway but as
you can clearly see it's a very safe
system because it does have a rail look
along each row and therefore there
wouldn't be the slightest possibility of
significant forward movement or thawed
tippling of fans welcome one of the
reasons people site when they're
advocating more standing is that it will
bring down ticket prices but given the
economics of the game would that really
happen well it could bring down the
ticket prices certainly and certainly if
we look at the Premier League's recent
media deal they've got more than enough
money any way to bring down ticket
prices but but you can get more people
into a safe standing area than into the
same area that
an all-seater stadium so they could
bring down ticket prices without losing
significant amount of revenue but I
think the main argument is really is one
of choice there's a significant number
of fans want to stand and those who
don't want to stand don't want to have
to stand because they're the people are
standing in front of them in the seated
area so everybody's a winner we
represent half a million football fans
and there's no way on earth that we
would ever support anything that put the
safety of our members significantly at
risk